I have so many questions to talk to you
two about but I guess the the first
thing is the script is so so well
written and so I learned so much
what what has this process or can you
describe a little bit of working
together on this thing because so much
is classified but yet the film is able
to portray so much that you know what I
mean they're towing that line well you
answered a bit of your own question so
much is classified that we actually
couldn't work together very much because
I felt an obligation to protect Dan from
the process and so I read the report and
I would certainly ask him questions
about how does this footnote here you
know footnote 428 informed footnote
1,000 it seems like there's a connection
am i imagining it so we could have those
kinds of very like deep in the weeds
conversations the great thing about
having the report was it provided kind
of an organizing principle for the
script it kind of goes detainee by
detainee and I picked a few of those
that I felt were good examples for the
gist of the whole whole you know summary
and you know and I kind of started there
and we did a lot of table reads which I
had not ever done before with the script
and it really helped me like track
redundancy you know give kind of an arc
to what Adam was gonna do by by figuring
out how to progress his frustration with
what he was doing I have to ask you what
after giving so much of your life to
this report what was it like the first
time seeing it and did you have to like
be alone for a while afterwards after
the film are after during the report
after the film after watching it well
yeah you know actually the first time I
really took in the film was at Sundance
actually believe it or not it's the
first time I saw it on the big screen
obviously it's it's it's impactful it's
hard it's hard to watch right in the
sense for me I was so closely connected
to it over seven years but Scott does
it's important work right the content of
that report itself it's really
me that people know it and they learn
from it and there's some degree to
accountability there and I make sure
that we don't do it again
so it's worth any personal sacrifice in
terms of doing the report and and any
young uncomfortableness and so much as
it's it brings up a period of time in
your life when you're really dedicated
to something and and obsessed about it
perhaps one of the things
listen there's many things about the
script that I love but one of the things
is that it never treats the it never
dumbs itself down for the audience and
I'm sort of curious could you sort of
talk about because I would imagine
there's some producers or maybe some
people that are like can we you know
that that line of you know main anyway
well is I'm thrilled to hear you say
that
you know one of the maybe the only
benefit of never you know having
financing until two weeks before we shot
is we didn't have you know I didn't have
a lot of voices to answer to other than
Jennifer Fox my producer or the actors
Steven Soderbergh and I don't like going
to a movie and having a bunch of
expositional scenes and getting way
ahead of the story and you know steven
has always encouraged me that if you
write a good script and you get people
leaning in and are curious they'll
they'll catch up and in fact the
expositional stuff tends to put them off
because they already know and you know
so I'm thrilled to hear you say that
because I want to treat the audience
with respect the thing that that I find
so insane is the amount of dialogue that
is delivered in this film and you shot
in 26 days I don't understand how you
pulled that off and I want to know how
did you film this in 26 days with the
amount of dialogue you need to deliver I
got a lot of help from my line producer
Cary aren't in terms of organizing
things and there were difficult
decisions about combining locations and
you know really spent a lot of time
crawling around finding new angles in
spaces we had been before but the you
know the the best thing was everybody
showed up you know with with
with their you know their lines and you
know like the scene with Corey Stoll and
Adam you know which is right at the
center of the movie you know that's six
pages and you know we shot it in half a
day and it was because those guys were
so off-book and in fact I had divided it
up into three acts and had figured out
all of my camera positions before they
got there and when they got there I said
okay we're just going to do two pages
and I'm going to reset and then I know
we want to do this all as a piece and so
every take was all six pages and you
know when you get into an edit room
that's that's gold that's crazy
many more questions I will talk to any
other point oh thanks thank you again
for service I looked reconnect we'll
talk